This is episode three of Not Built For This. The price is wrong. And now your hostess on The Price is Right, here she is Arlene Pramson. Hi. Welcome to The Price is Right. Well, Bill Coleridge- The earliest seasons of The Price is Right had a wide range of prizes. There was, of course, your standard game show fare,
这里是《不适于此》第三集。价格不对。现在是《价格猜猜看》的主持人，她就是阿琳·普拉姆森。嗨。欢迎来到《价格猜猜看》。那么，比尔·科尔里奇——《价格猜猜看》最早的几季有着各种各样的奖品。当然，有你们标准的电视游戏节目奖品，
things like cars, jewelry, furniture. But some items were more outlandish. So just look over to the left for the first item to go up for bids on The Price is Right. A submarine. Oh! This is from an episode that ran back in 1961. All four contestants are laughing as this submersible appears stage left.
比如汽车、珠宝、家具。但有些物品更加离奇。所以，请看左边，这是《价格猜猜看》上第一件竞标的物品。一艘潜水艇。噢！这是1961年播出的某一集。当这艘微型潜水艇从舞台左侧出现时，所有四位参赛者都在大笑。
It looks like a life-sized version of something you'd pull out of the bottom of a cereal box. Not exactly sea-worthy. Alrighty. Well now, Mrs. Patrick, we're going to start with you, and you got an airplane last week. Let's see if you can go underwater this week. The minimum will be $100. I think I'll be started at $100.
它看起来就像你从麦片盒底部掏出来的东西的真人大小版。完全不适航。好吧。那么，帕特里克太太，我们从你开始，你上周得到了一架飞机。让我们看看你这周能不能潜水。最低出价将是100美元。我想我从100美元开始。
All right. What do you say, Mr. Talmad? Mrs. Patrick missed out on that submarine, but the last prize of the day was something that all of the contestants seemed genuinely excited about. A home in Florida. A home in Cape Coral, Florida. The living room is spacious, light and airy,
好的。你觉得呢，塔尔马德先生？帕特里克太太错过了那艘潜水艇，但当天的最后一件奖品是所有参赛者似乎都由衷兴奋的东西。佛罗里达的一栋房子。一栋位于佛罗里达州科勒尔角（Cape Coral）的房子。客厅宽敞、明亮、通透，
with a sliding glass wall that leads to a screened sun porch. The guessing went on for a few rounds, and eventually the contestants narrowed in on a number. $15,070, and the winner is Mrs. Patrick. When Mrs. Patrick won her home in Cape Coral, the city wasn't even fully built yet. The developers were still in the process of converting miles of swamp and coastal wetlands into a middle-class paradise,
有一扇通往配有纱窗的日光门廊的推拉玻璃墙。竞猜进行了好几轮，最终参赛者们将数字锁定在一个范围内。15,070美元，获胜者是帕特里克太太。当帕特里克太太赢得她在科勒尔角的房子时，这座城市甚至还没有完全建成。开发商当时仍在将数英里的沼泽和海岸湿地改造成中产阶级的天堂，
a kind of coastal Leavitt town, where even a schoolteacher could afford to live the Florida dream. Getting here is only the beginning of all the fun and excitement. Wait until you see what's been planned for you once you arrive at Cave Coral. The city is located in southwest Florida,
一种沿海的莱维顿（Levittown），在那里连学校老师也买得起、住得起佛罗里达梦。来到这里只是所有快乐和兴奋的开始。等到你看看为你抵达科勒尔角后所做好的规划。这座城市位于佛罗里达州西南部，
right where the mouth of the Caloosahatchee River empties into the Gulf of Mexico. And the founders had big plans for the community, not just a subdivision or a small town, but a whole city with canals running through residents' backyards. So many canals that in magazines and radio ads, Cape Coral billed itself as a waterfront wonderland.
就在卡卢萨哈奇河（Caloosahatchee River）河口注入墨西哥湾的地方。创始人们对这个社区有着宏伟的规划，不仅仅是一个分块住宅区或小镇，而是一座运河穿过居民后院的完整城市。运河多到在杂志和电台广告中，科勒尔角将自己标榜为海滨仙境。
Even that home on the Price is Right was a marketing tool. Just one of the many ways the developers tried to reach cold, stricken northerners and retirees who were ready for the good life. For a long time, the promise of balmy winters and cheap housing drew families to Florida, including mine. Jason DeLeon is a 99PI producer and our resident Florida man. Growing up, my parents were in the real estate business, as was my brother, some cousins, and lots of close friends too. Which is very Florida.
甚至《价格猜猜看》里的那栋房子也是一种营销工具。这只是开发商试图触及饱受寒冷折磨的北方人和准备好享受美好生活的退休人员的众多方法之一。长久以来，温和的冬天和廉价住房的承诺吸引着各个家庭来到佛罗里达，包括我的家人。杰森·德莱昂（Jason DeLeon）是99PI的制作人，也是我们的常驻佛罗里达人。在我的成长过程中，我的父母从事房地产行业，我哥哥、一些表亲以及很多挚友也是如此。这非常“佛罗里达”。
So from a young age, I got to see up close how this alchemy of water and sun captivated people. But the Florida Dream is not what it used to be. As you hear this, the state is in the middle of one of the most dangerous hurricane seasons it's ever faced. That's because the seas around Florida are really hot. And that's fueling more intense storms, increasing the potential for destruction. The Florida coast has already been battered by one massive storm this summer, and the worst weeks of hurricane season are still to come.
所以从小我就近距离地看到了水和阳光的这种奇妙组合是如何迷住人们的。但佛罗里达梦已不复从前。当你听到这档节目时，该州正处于它所面临的最危险的飓风季之一。那是因为佛罗里达周边的海洋非常热。这正在助长更强烈的风暴，增加了破坏潜力。今年夏天，佛罗里达海岸已经受到了一场巨大风暴的重创，而飓风季最糟糕的几周还在后头。
And all across the state, Floridians are starting to really feel the cost of living on America's riskiest peninsula. Because climate change isn't only generating harsher weather, it's hitting people's bank accounts. For years, the cost of owning a home in Florida has been going up. But nowhere has that change been more dramatic than in the price people are paying for insurance. Insurance companies are not climate activists, but they might know more about climate risk than just about anyone. And as the storms get more extreme and unpredictable, a lot of insurers are running the numbers on Florida and realizing that the math just isn't working anymore.
全州上下，佛罗里达人开始真正感受到生活在全美风险最高半岛上的代价。因为气候变化不仅在制造更恶劣的天气，还在冲击人们的银行账户。多年来，在佛罗里达拥有房屋的成本一直在上涨。但这种变化没有哪里比人们为保险支付的价格更戏剧化了。保险公司不是气候活动人士，但他们对气候风险的了解可能比任何人都多。随着风暴变得更加极端和不可预测，许多保险公司正在对佛罗里达进行数据核算，并意识到这种数学计算已经行不通了。
For decades, low-cost insurance helped mask the risks of living on the coasts of southwest Florida. However, right now a climate correction is underway. Prices are skyrocketing, and in this new financial reality, residents of Cape Coral are realizing that their waterfront wonderland was just not built for this. I'm Emmett Fitzgerald. Jason, we'll take it from here. The story of Cape Coral's insurance crisis really begins with the founders of the city, a pair of hucksters named Jack and Leonard Rosen.
几十年来，低成本保险掩盖了居住在佛罗里达州西南部海岸的风险。然而，此刻一场气候修正正在进行中。价格飞涨，在这个新的金融现实中，科勒尔角的居民们意识到他们的海滨仙境根本不适于此。我是埃米特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）。杰森，我们从这里接管。科勒尔角保险危机的历史实际上始于这座城市的奠基人，一对名叫杰克（Jack）和伦纳德·罗森（Leonard Rosen）的骗子。
The Rosens were two brothers from Baltimore, self-made, tough. I mean, I admire their story. This is Jason Vuek, the historian who grew up in a town north of Cape Coral. Jason wrote about the Rosen brothers in his book, The Swamp Peddlers. They relied on each other. They fought with each other. They hated each other, but they loved each other as only brothers could. And they grew up. They were both carnival barkers. Like literal carnival barkers.
罗森兄弟是来自巴尔的摩的两兄弟，白手起家，强悍。我的意思是，我很佩服他们的故事。这是杰森·维克（Jason Vuek），一位在科勒尔角以北的一个小镇长大的历史学家。杰森在他的书《沼泽贩子》（The Swamp Peddlers）中写到了罗森兄弟。他们彼此依靠。他们互相争吵。他们互相憎恨，但他们又像只有兄弟才能做到的那样深爱着彼此。他们长大了。他们俩都是嘉年华叫卖员。字面意义上的嘉年华叫卖员。
Step right up. Jack Rosen was the youngest, the big picture operations type. In the various businesses he had with his brother, he was often behind the scenes running the show. Because Leonard, he was a born salesman. A complete and total extrovert who was loud and brash, the kind of guy who was known to show up to board meetings wearing sneakers and tennis shorts. Even if Leonard was kind of a lot to be around, he had a way of drawing people in, a trait that carried over into the Rosen's first major business success in the early 1950s. They sold many gallons of a shampoo mixed in a bathtub
快来瞧一瞧。杰克·罗森是弟弟，负责大局运营类的工作。在他和哥哥经营的各种生意中，他通常在幕后掌管全局。因为伦纳德是个天生的推销员。一个彻头彻尾的外向者，声音洪亮、性格张扬，就是那种被众所周知会穿着运动鞋和网球短裤出席董事会会议的人。即使伦纳德这人有点难以应付，但他有一种吸引人们的特质，这种特质延续到了罗森兄弟在20世纪50年代初期的第一笔重大商业成功中。他们在一只浴缸里混合销售了许多加仑的洗发水，
with lanolin. Charles Antel's Lanolin Shampoo. Yes, ladies, a luxurious lanolin lab of shampoo created by Charles Antel to bring a new glamour, a clean, rich softness to your hair. You know, lanolin comes from wool and it's supposed to have illust you know, lustrative power. I don't know what it does, but it doesn't do much.
里面加了羊毛脂。查尔斯·安特尔羊毛脂洗发水（Charles Antel's Lanolin Shampoo）。是的，女士们，由查尔斯·安特尔创造的豪华羊毛脂洗发水，为您的秀发带来崭新的魅力、洁净而浓郁的柔顺感。你知道，羊毛脂来自羊毛，它应该有……你知道的，增光的力量。我不知道它有什么用，但其实没多大用。
And it'd say things like, you've ever seen a bald sheep? No. Lanolin. And they made millions. With all the money they made selling this ludicrous hair stuff, the Rosens wanted to strike out on a new venture. Leonard had arthritis, and he heard that the climate down in Florida could be good for him.
他们会说这样的话：你见过秃毛羊吗？没有。羊毛脂。然后他们赚了几百万。有了靠卖这些滑稽的头发产品赚来的所有钱，罗森兄弟想要开辟一项新事业。伦纳德患有关节炎，他听说佛罗里达南部的气候可能对他的病情有好处。
And it was on a trip down to the Sunshine State, he noticed something new was afoot in the real estate market. People weren't just dropping in for vacation anymore. They were buying. And so the brothers looked at each other and asked, Why are we selling shampoo for a dollar a bottle when Americans are paying a thousand a lot to move to Florida? And so they moved to Florida. They specifically went to Florida to find land to sell because they were they were getting out of the shampoo business with the money they had made and they were going to go to Florida and they were going for the gold.
正是在去阳光之州的旅行中，他们注意到房地产市场正在发生一些新变化。人们不再只是顺道来度假了。他们在买房。于是两兄弟相视一眼，问道：“当美国人花一千块买一块地来搬到佛罗里达时，我们为什么还要以一美元一瓶的价格卖洗发水呢？”于是他们搬到了佛罗里达。他们去佛罗里达专门寻找要出售的土地，因为他们用赚来的钱退出了洗发水行业，他们要前往佛罗里达，去淘金。
In 1957, Jack and Leonard Rosen purchased the first few acres of what would become Cape Coral. For generations, this bit of land on Florida's Gulf Coast belonged to the native Colusa. They built homes and other structures atop these giant shell mounds, which kept them high and dry during the wet season. But when the Rosen showed up in the 1950s, this land was mostly uninhabited swamp — a place that even locals only visited briefly to hunt deer and wild hogs. You know, it was marshy and mangrovey. You know, the mangrove mud, you know, you walk by mangroves, you put your shoe in the mud, you don't get it back. Right? I mean, this is stinky, tough.
1957年，杰克和伦纳德·罗森买下了后来成为科勒尔角的第一批土地。世世代代，佛罗里达墨西哥湾沿岸的这片土地属于当地的卡卢萨（Colusa）原住民。他们在这些巨大的贝壳丘顶上建造房屋和其他建筑，这使他们在雨季也能保持高处干燥。但当罗森兄弟在20世纪50年代出现时，这片土地基本上是无人居住的沼泽——一个连当地人也只是短暂造访去猎鹿和野猪的地方。你知道，那里泥泞且长满红树林。你知道，红树林的泥，你知道的，你从红树林旁走过，把鞋子踩进泥里，就再也拔不出来了。对吧？我的意思是，又臭又难搞。
It's beautiful Florida nature, but it's not a place that's, you know, you want to hang out much. Still, the Rosens paid no attention to that. And really, neither did anyone else. Local and state officials did nothing to prevent development in these dubious and sometimes dangerous areas. In fact, it was the total opposite. They rolled out the red carpet to developers who vowed to drain these swamps and build
这是美丽的佛罗里达自然风光，但它不是一个你想多待的地方。尽管如此，罗森兄弟对此根本不在意。说实话，其他人也没在意。地方和州官员没有采取任何措施来阻止在这些可疑有时甚至危险的地区的开发。事实上，情况恰恰相反。他们向那些誓言要排干这些沼泽并建造
the next suburban paradise. There were no laws about development on county land in Florida. You could build whatever. You could build the Taj Mahal in 1957 without a permit. Nobody would stop you. In fact, they were thrilled that somebody would build out there. The Rosens created a company called Golf American to purchase and develop Cape Coral. And to get the land high enough to reasonably put a house on,
下一个市郊天堂的开发商铺红地毯。在佛罗里达州，没有关于在县属土地上开发的法律。你可以建造任何东西。1957年，你甚至可以在没有许可证的情况下建造泰姬陵。没有人会阻止你。事实上，他们很高兴有人能在那里大兴土木。罗森兄弟创建了一家名为“海湾美洲”（Golf American）的公司来购买和开发科勒尔角。为了把土地垫高到足以合理建造房屋的高度，
they elevated it five and a half feet above sea level, which is not a lot. I mean, I'm 5'7 on a good day. Still, getting these houses above the water required a ton of manpower and big machinery. Getting these houses above the water required a ton of manpower and big machinery. Down by the Caloosahatchee River, massive draglines and dredges carved the path inland, creating miles and miles worth of canals. Aerial photos of all these waterways snaking through residents' backyards would soon wind up on postcards and in magazines. But they weren't just for show, because the canals are also how the Rosens created the actual land that they would eventually build houses on.
他们将其高出海平面五点五英尺，这其实并不算高。我的意思是，我状态好的时候也才5英尺7英寸。尽管如此，要让这些房子高出水面，仍然需要大量的劳动力和大型机械。要让这些房子高出水面，仍然需要大量的劳动力和大型机械。在卡卢萨哈奇河畔，巨大的索斗铲和疏浚机在内陆开辟出道路，修建了数英里长的运河。所有这些蜿蜒穿过居民后院的水道的航拍照片很快就会出现在明信片和杂志上。但它们不只是为了好看，因为运河也是罗森兄弟用来创造他们最终将在上面建造房屋的实际土地的方式。
As the dredges work their way through this swampy terrain, they dump all that dirt from the bottom of the river in giant piles alongside it. And because all that crud from the riverbed is free, the Rosens simply graded these piles of muck and voila, land. And so this isn't beach sand that you're pulling up. It smells. It's horrible. Flies. You know, the dead shells, the dead sea crabs, the dead vegetation.
当疏浚机在这片沼泽地形中作业时，它们把河底的所有泥土倾倒在河道旁边巨大的堆积物中。由于河床里的所有这些垃圾都是免费的，罗森兄弟只需将这些污泥堆平整，瞧，土地就有了。所以这不是你捞起来的海滩沙子。它有气味。太可怕了。苍蝇。你知道的，死贝壳、死海蟹、死去的植物。
And it was just some of the descriptions from Cape Coral in the early days. It was kind of biblical. Some of the descriptions from Cape Coral in the early days, it was kind of biblical. Developments like Cape Coral destroyed mangroves and paved over wetlands, areas that naturally absorb floodwaters and reduce storm surges. Experts call this land a hurricane buffer zone. But the Rosans and developers all over Florida were tearing these environments apart and building homes there instead. Residential lots in Golf American's new city were sold on installments, $20 down and $20 a month.
这也是早期对科勒尔角的一些描述。这有点像《圣经》里的描述。早期对科勒尔角的一些描述，这有点像《圣经》里的描述。像科勒尔角这样的开发项目摧毁了红树林，并在湿地上铺上了水泥，这些区域本可以自然吸收洪水并减弱风暴潮。专家称这片土地为飓风缓冲区。但罗森兄弟和佛罗里达州各地的开发商却在撕裂这些环境，并在那里建造房屋。“海湾美洲”新城市里的住宅用地采取分期付款的方式出售，首付20美元，每月20美元。
In some of the earliest layouts, you can see tens of thousands of home sites color-coded as tiny, equally sized rectangles. color-coded as tiny, equally sized rectangles. At first, Golf American didn't even bother to include space in the plans for a school or a grocery store. They wanted to squeeze as many lots as they could out of this swamp. And as it turns out, there was a real appetite for what they were selling.
在一些最早的规划图上，你可以看到成千上万的宅基地被用颜色代码标成微小的、大小相等的长方形。被用颜色代码标成微小的、大小相等的长方形。起初，“海湾美洲”甚至懒得在规划中为学校或杂货店留出空间。他们想从这片沼泽里榨取出尽可能多的地块。事实证明，人们对他们出售的东西确实有着极大的兴趣。
We were motivating people to leave their home up north and come down here and live with us. So we didn't tell no lies, we didn't even stretch the truth. This is Joseph Razo, a salesman at Golf American. In an old recording, Joseph spoke about his time at the company selling this new city on the water. When he first arrived, Cape Coral was actually hit by a massive hurricane, ripping roofs off houses and flooding some roads and homes.
我们在激励人们离开北方的家园，来到这里和我们一起生活。所以我们没有说谎，我们甚至没有夸大事实。这是约瑟夫·拉佐（Joseph Razo），“海湾美洲”的一名销售人员。在一段旧录音中，约瑟夫谈到了他在该公司销售这座水上新城市的经历。他刚到时，科勒尔角实际上遭到了一场巨大飓风的袭击，风暴掀掉了房屋的屋顶，并淹没了部分道路和房屋。
But he says that didn't stop the company from forging ahead. The very next day we sold a couple houses and we sold lots of land with the people that came here. Like I said, the people that came down believed in the things we told them. And they believed and they bought it. Golf American's marketing was unlike anything Florida had ever seen. At one point, the company spent more money advertising the Florida lifestyle than the state of Florida did. They hired teams to travel the Northeast and the Midwest.
但他表示，这并没有阻止公司继续前进。就在第二天，我们卖出了好几栋房子，并且向来到这里的人们出售了大量的土地。就像我说的，来到这里的人们相信我们告诉他们的事情。他们相信了，也就买下了。“海湾美洲”的营销是佛罗里达前所未见的。有一段时间，该公司在宣传佛罗里达生活方式上花的钱比佛罗里达州政府还要多。他们雇佣团队前往东北部和中西部。
At local hotels, they'd offer customers free chicken dinners and show them a movie about Cape Coral. Sometimes salespeople would close the deal by the end of the night. And for anyone who still needed a little convincing, Golf American booked them on an all-expense paid trip down to their waterfront wonderland. We used to bring them here by air, by bus, by train, by boat, anywhere that we could bring them here, we brought them here. So it would fly you in and you'd bring your kids and you would stay in their clutches,
在当地的酒店里，他们会向客户提供免费的鸡肉晚餐，并向他们播放一部关于科勒尔角的电影。有时销售人员在当晚结束前就能敲定交易。对于任何仍然需要一点说服力的人，“海湾美洲”会为他们预订一次全包费用的旅行，带他们前往他们的水上仙境。我们过去常常用飞机、公交车、火车、轮船把他们带到这里，只要能把他们带到这里的任何方式，我们都用上了。所以它会用飞机把你接来，你带着孩子，然后你会留在他们的掌控之中，
so in their hotel, within their bus route, and they had you captive. Gloria Razo Tate is Joseph Razo's daughter. She was just nine years old when the family moved to Cape Coral. And when her dad joined the sales team, she got a job of her own, too. It was just a little more informal. And my sister and I were babysitters. So we would take the kids and say, you would take the kids, the people who came. Yes. Who came on the flying by and take them to the beach.
也就是在他们的酒店里，沿着他们的巴士路线，他们把你“软禁”了。格洛里亚·拉佐·泰特（Gloria Razo Tate）是约瑟夫·拉佐的女儿。当全家搬到科勒尔角时，她才九岁。当她父亲加入销售团队时，她也找到了自己的工作。只是稍微没那么正式。我和我姐姐是临时保姆。所以我们会带走那些孩子，也就是说，你会带走那些孩子，那些来的人。是的。乘飞机来的人，带他们去海滩。
And, you know, they would be in love with this place. We want to move here. We want to move here. We fed them breakfast. We fed them lunch. We fed them dinner. Prime rib. Never cheap.
然后，你知道的，他们会爱上这个地方。“我们想搬到这里。我们想搬到这里。”我们给他们提供早餐。我们给他们提供午餐。我们给他们提供晚餐。优质肋排。绝不含糊。
I was so sick of prime rib, you couldn't believe it. Once the deal closed, a Gulf American pilot would fly you up into Cessna to show you your slice of paradise. From the sky, customers would see this Pac-Man-like maze of canals and houses. By the late 1960s, Golf American had sold so many lots, it was sometimes hard to tell a customer just which piece of land was theirs. And the pilot has a bag of flour or sugar, and he leans out the window and he goes, your lot is right there.
我吃优质肋排吃到直反胃，你绝对想象不到。一旦交易敲定，“海湾美洲”的飞行员就会用塞斯纳飞机带你飞上天空，向你展示你那片世外桃源。从空中，客户会看到这个像吃豆人一样的运河和房屋迷宫。到了20世纪60年代末，“海湾美洲”卖出了太多的地块，有时很难准确告诉客户哪一块地到底是他们的。飞行员手里拿着一袋面粉或糖，他把身子探出窗外说，你的地就在那儿。
And he drops the bag and the bag lands on the ground and goes, boof. This pluffle widened, who knows where it went and who knows where that land was. I mean, let's be honest, a lot of people had no clue what they were buying in Florida. But, you know, that's the way it rolled. Jack and Leonard Rosen started out like a lot of other Florida developers, trying to spit shine some swampy land to sell to a bunch of dopes up north. And the plan? It worked. Lots of people started moving to their city.
然后他把袋子扔下去，袋子掉在地上，发出“扑”的一声。这团粉末散开，谁知道它飘到了哪里，谁又知道那块地到底在哪里。我的意思是，老实说，很多人根本不知道自己在佛罗里达买的是什么。但是，你知道，事情就是这样运作的。杰克和伦纳德·罗森的起步和其他许多佛罗里达开发商一样，试图把一些沼泽地稍微粉饰一下，卖给北方的一群笨蛋。而这个计划？成功了。很多人开始搬到他们的城市。
Between 1970 and 1980, the population of Cape Coral tripled to over 30,000. And as time went on, the land just kept filling in. Today, more than 200,000 people call the city home. But Cape Coral has a problem. One that stems from its original sin. The whole premise of the city was to use canals to put as many single-family homes on the water as they possibly could. Today, it has over 400 miles worth of canals, the most of any city anywhere in the world. However, as the seas rise and storms get worse and worse, what used to be
在1970年到1980年间，科勒尔角的人口增加了两倍，达到3万多人。随着时间的推移，这片土地不断被填满。如今，超过20万人将这座城市称为家园。但科勒尔角有一个问题。一个源于其原罪的问题。这座城市的整个前提就是利用运河，尽可能多地将单户住宅建在水面上。如今，它拥有超过400英里长的运河，是世界上任何城市中最多的。然而，随着海平面上升以及风暴变得越来越糟，曾经是
Cape Coral's biggest asset has turned into its biggest liability. You know, when do these canal front properties that weren't really smart to build in the beginning, now they're downright dangerous to live on? Some huge number of Cape Coral is flood prone as we speak. A recent study suggests that nearly 90% of properties in Cape Coral are at risk of flooding. That's more than 110,000 homes, the most of any city in Florida. The development of all this swampy land was risky even before the effects of climate change became super clear.
科勒尔角最大资产的东西已经变成了它最大的负债。你知道的，这些水滨房产起初建造时就不是很明智，现在住在上面到底什么时候会变得彻头彻尾的危险？据我们所知，科勒尔角有相当大比例的地区容易发生洪水。最近的一项研究表明，科勒尔角近90%的房产面临洪水风险。这超过了110,000栋房屋，是佛罗里达州所有城市中最高的。在气候变化的影響变得超级明显之前，开发所有这些沼泽土地就已经充满了风险。
But at the same time the Razzos and the Rosens were selling the city, there was another development happening. This time in the insurance market. And it would make it harder for newcomers to really understand the true risks of living in Cape Coral. After the break, how we all ended up paying for the Florida dream. In the 1950s, America was in the middle of the post-war housing boom, and lots of construction was happening. It just wasn't always in the safest places.
但与此同时，当拉佐家族和罗森家族在兜售这座城市时，另一场发展正在发生。这一次是在保险市场上。这会让新来者更加难以真正理解居住在科勒尔角的真实风险。休息之后，我们将探讨我们是如何最终为佛罗里达梦买单的。20世纪50年代，美国正处于战后住房热潮的中期，大量的建设正在进行中。只是这些建设并不总是在最安全的地方。
That was especially true in Florida, where the Rosens were dredging and filling swamps at warp speed. Those types of changes to the landscape come back to haunt communities because the water still comes and still needs somewhere to go. This is Carolyn Kuski. She studies policy and climate risk at the Environmental Defense Fund. Carolyn says that communities that build themselves on top of wetlands, unsurprisingly, have a greater chance of flooding. And for a long time, if residents wanted to insure against that risk, they couldn't.
佛罗里达州尤其如此，罗森兄弟当时正在以极快的速度疏浚和填埋沼泽。那种对地貌的改变最终会反过来困扰社区，因为水依然会涌来，而且仍然需要一个去处。这是卡罗琳·库斯基（Caroline Kuski）。她在环境防卫基金会（Environmental Defense Fund）研究政策和气候风险不足为奇的是，卡罗琳表示，建在湿地之上的社区发生洪水的几率更高。在很长一段时间里，如果居民想要为这种风险投保，他们是做不到的。
No private companies wanted to sell flood insurance because a big flood could bankrupt and actually had bankrupted a lot of insurers. So the cost of helping homeowners rebuild after a flood increasingly fell to the federal government, which found itself paying out loads of money in disaster aid. And there's start being conversations that disaster aid is getting to be pretty pricey for the federal government and insurance would be a way to help spread the cost, but also to encourage better development in our floodplains. And so the sort of national conversation around a potential flood insurance program begins
没有私营公司愿意出售洪水保险，因为一场大洪水可能会让许多保险公司破产，事实上也确实让许多保险公司破产了。因此，帮助房主在洪水后重建家园的成本越来越多地落在了联邦政府头上，政府发现自己在灾难援助上支付了巨额资金。并且开始出现这样的对话：对于联邦政府来说，灾难援助变得相当昂贵，而保险将是一种帮助分担成本的方式，同时也是为了鼓励在我们的洪泛区进行更好的开发。因此，围绕潜在洪水保险计划的全国性讨论开始于
in the 50s and 60s and then is finally adopted in 1968. The National Flood Insurance Program, or the NFIP, is an insurance program run by the federal government. And one of its main goals was to discourage people from buying in places they probably shouldn't. Residents who purchase flood insurance policies are having to see the cost of risk when they make those premium payments. And the thought is that that is then going to encourage people to be more careful about moving into incredibly risky areas. FEMA, who runs the NFIP, knew it needed a critical mass
20世纪50年代和60年代，并最终于1968年通过。国家洪水保险计划（简称NFIP）是由联邦政府运营的一项保险计划。其主要目标之一是劝阻人们在不该买房的地方买房。购买洪水保险保单的居民在支付这些保费时，不得不直面风险的成本。其想法是，这反过来将鼓励人们在搬入风险极高的地区时更加谨慎。运营NFIP的联邦机构联邦紧急事务管理局（FEMA）深知它需要一定规模的
of customers to make the program work. Insurance, after all, is a numbers game. The more people you get inside the program, the more you can spread out the cost of a disaster. But at least initially, communities weren't like, hell yeah, a flood insurance. Because as it turns out, it's really hard to get people to buy a thing for something that might happen at some point in the future. So to get homeowners into the program, the federal government did two things.
客户群才能让该计划发挥作用。毕竟，保险是一场数字游戏。你让越多的人加入这个计划，你就能越好地分担灾难的成本。但至少在最初，社区并没有表现出“太棒了，有洪水保险”的态度。因为事实证明，要让人们为未来某个时刻可能发生的事件去买单是非常困难的。因此，为了让房主加入该计划，联邦政府做了两件事。
First, they mandated that if you have a mortgage on a house in a high-risk flood zone, you had to buy flood insurance. Which, you know, that makes good sense. And crucially, they also offered residents living in flood-prone communities a subsidy, or what's essentially a discount. Giving people the benefits of flood insurance, but at a cheaper rate than the actual risk they faced. And so this discount is built into flood insurance prices from the beginning. And the thought was it would phase out quickly as homes turned over, newer homes were built,
首先，他们强制规定，如果你在高风险洪泛区的房屋有抵押贷款，你就必须购买洪水保险。这，你知道的，这很有道理。至关重要的是，他们还向生活在易受洪水影响的社区的居民提供补贴，或者本质上就是折扣。让人们享受洪水保险的好处，但费率比他们实际上面临的风险更便宜。因此，这种折扣从一开始就内置在洪水保险价格中。当时的设想是，随着房屋转手、新房建成，这种折扣会迅速逐步取消，
and it's supposed to be eliminated if there's major retrofits or anything. And it turned out to be just really sticky. At least early on, there were some good reasons for the discount. FEMA didn't want to punish residents who had already purchased homes in a flood zone, even before the program existed. So the discount was a tool to help ease people in. And it was supposed to eventually go away, but it just never did. And there are other ways the flood insurance program
并且如果进行了重大改造等，它本应被取消。但事实证明，这个政策非常顽固。至少在早期，提供折扣有一些充分的理由。FEMA不想惩罚那些甚至在计划存在之前就已经在洪泛区买房的居民。因此，折扣是帮助人们过渡的工具。它本应最终消失，但它就是从未消失。此外，洪水保险计划
has underpriced risk. For one, FEMA has historically used flood maps to price premiums, but those maps are notoriously outdated and often fail to accurately identify flood prone areas. So over the years, lots of people with significant flood risk were shown on the map as living in a pretty safe area.
低估风险还有其他方式。一方面，FEMA历史上一直使用洪水地图来定价保费，但这些地图出了名的过时，往往无法准确识别易受洪水影响的地区。因此多年来，许多面临重大洪水风险的人在地图上被显示为生活在相当安全的区域。
And they ended up getting cheaper rates because of it. The current system greatly underprices flood insurance, which is why it's so great for those of us who buy flood insurance. We think it's great. Bill Spikowski is a city planner who lives just outside of Cape Coral. I think I pay $700 a year for my house. $700 a year for flood insurance. Even Bill acknowledges that this is a bargain.
正因为如此，他们最终获得了更便宜的费率。当前的系统极大地低估了洪水保险的价格，这就是为什么对于我们这些购买洪水保险的人来说它太棒了。我们觉得这太棒了。比尔·斯皮科夫斯基（Bill Spikowski）是一位住在科勒尔角郊外的城市规划师。我想我每年为我的房子支付700美元。每年700美元的洪水保险。连比尔也承认这很划算。
He says the flood insurance program holds a lot of power over this part of the country. In Cape Coral alone, there are over 27,000 flood insurance policies through the NFIP. And for decades, lots of residents have been getting a pretty sweet deal because flood insurance was just cheaper than it should have been, particularly for the wealthiest homeowners. FEMA knows that its rates have been a problem.
他说，洪水保险计划对这个国家的部分地区拥有很大的控制权。仅在科勒尔角，就有通过NFIP购买的超过27,000份洪水保险保单。几十年来，许多居民一直享受着相当不错的优惠，因为洪水保险比它原本应该的价格便宜，特别是对于最富有的房主而言。FEMA深知其费率一直是个问题。
It's just that any time they try to correct them, everyone revolts. As soon as the new insurance rates come out, citizens call their congressmen and the congressmen being elected officials, scream and yell, how could you do this? And they roll it back. The reason FEMA wants to raise rates is because the program runs at a massive deficit to the tune of some $20 billion. So as disasters keep piling on, the program has to borrow from us taxpayers to help pay its obligations. And the NFIP hasn't just been a boon to Florida homeowners, but for local governments who
只是每当他们试图对其进行纠正时，每个人都会反抗。一旦新的保险费率出台，公民就会打电话给他们的国会议员，而国会议员作为民选官员，就会大喊大叫：“你们怎么能这么做？”然后他们又将其撤回。FEMA想要提高费率的原因是该计划存在巨额赤字，高达约200亿美元。因此，随着灾难不断叠加，该计划不得不向我们纳税人借钱来帮助支付其债务。并且，NFIP不仅对佛罗里达州的房主是一个福音，对那些
want to see their cities grow. Local governments have a bit of a perverse incentive to allow excessive development in risky areas because they get the property tax revenue from it. But when those homes are damaged, the local government doesn't pay any of the costs of those damages. So they just get the nice benefits in the safe years and don't have to deal with it. When it floods, it's not their problem. It's on the owner or the federal government. In theory, the NFIP was supposed to act as a disincentive, a tool that would make living in the floodplains pricey and even steer some residents outside of a flood zone.
希望看到城市不断发展的当地政府来说也是如此。地方政府有一种有点反常的动机，允许在危险地区进行过度的开发，因为他们可以从中获得房产税收入。但当这些房屋受损时，地方政府无需承担任何这些损失的成本。所以他们在安全年份里只享受好处，而不必处理烂摊子。当发生洪水时，这不是他们的问题。那是业主或联邦政府的事。理论上讲，NFIP本应起到一种威慑作用，成为一种让住在洪泛区成本高昂、甚至引导一些居民搬出洪泛区的工具。
But in reality, it hasn't worked out that way. The flood insurance program didn't rein in risky development. The discounted policies blinded people to the amount of risk they were actually taking on, which gave people an incentive to move into risky places like Cape Coral. After all, who wouldn't want their Florida dream subsidized by the federal government? Would Cape Coral exist as it is today had there not been a federal program as a backstop to cover against flood loss? Um, I don't... That's a good question.
但在现实中，情况并非如此。洪水保险计划并没有遏制危险的开发。打折的保单蒙蔽了人们的眼睛，让他们看不到自己实际承担的风险有多大，这促使人们搬进像科勒尔角这样危险的地方。毕竟，谁不想让自己的佛罗里达梦由联邦政府来补贴呢？如果没有一个联邦作为后盾来承保洪水损失的计划，科勒尔角还会像今天这样存在吗？嗯，我不知道……这是个好问题。
This is Wyatt Daltry. In addition to being on the planning team for Cape Coral, he's also the city's floodplain manager. I spoke to Wyatt a few months back in a small conference room down in Cape Coral City Hall. As far as the NFIP is concerned, I think we would still exist. I spoke to Wyatt a few months back in a small conference room down in Cape Coral City Hall. As far as the NFIP is concerned, I think we would still exist. I don't think we would be as large. So to some degree, it incentivized a growth in the series.
这是怀亚特·达尔特里（Wyatt Daltry）。除了是科勒尔角规划团队的成员外，他还是该市的洪泛区经理。几个月前，我在科勒尔角市政厅的一个小型会议室里采访了怀亚特。就NFIP而言，我认为我们仍然会存在。几个月前，我在科勒尔角市政厅的一个小型会议室里采访了怀亚特。就NFIP而言，我认为我们仍然会存在。我认为我们不会有这么大。所以在某种程度上，它刺激了该地区的增长。
I think it helped supercharge the growth we've seen in Southwest Florida. The flood insurance program was created to fill a gap left by the private market. And today, a similar dynamic is playing out on the state level with homeowners insurance. A policy that's completely separate from flood insurance and one that's required by lenders on all mortgages. So it affects even more people. Companies that sell homeowners insurance are starting to get really freaked out about climate change. And these businesses are deciding that some places have become so risky that they're effectively uninsurable. So rather than stick around and lose money, lots of companies are choosing to abandon the riskiest locations.
我认为它有助于超级推动我们在佛罗里达州西南部看到的增长。创建洪水保险计划是为了填补私营市场留下的空白。如今，类似的动态正在州一级与房主保险（homeowners insurance）一起上演。这是一项完全独立于洪水保险的政策，也是所有抵押贷款机构对所有抵押贷款都要求的政策。因此，它影响到更多的人。出售房屋保险的公司开始对气候变化感到真正恐慌。这些企业认定，某些地方的风险已经变得如此之高，以至于它们实际上无法投保。因此，许多公司与其留下来亏损，不如选择放弃风险最高的地段。
And just like with flood insurance, as those private companies leave, the state has had to step in, creating and expanding their own home insurance programs. 30 odd states now have a state-run program, including California, which is dramatically expanding that program right now to protect the state's economy and protect that growth that's so vital to the economy. A.B.
就像洪水保险一样，随着这些私营公司撤离，州政府不得不介入，创建并扩展他们自己的房屋保险计划。目前有30个左右的州拥有州营计划，包括加利福尼亚州，该州目前正在戏剧性地扩大该计划，以保护该州的经济并保护对经济至关重要的增长。
Rahm Lustgarten is a climate reporter at ProPublica. He says that these state-run home insurance programs act as a backstop, helping to keep lots of at-risk communities financially viable, which is a good thing. But they're also kind of obscuring and uncomfortable truth. Because when the private market says a place is uninsurable, that's a warning sign to everyone living in the area. This place is dangerous. But the state programs send a different message.
A.B. 拉姆·拉斯加滕（A.B. Rahm Lustgarten）是ProPublica的气候记者。他表示，这些州营的房屋保险计划充当了后盾，有助于保持许多处于危险之中的社区在财务上能够维持下去，这是一件好事。但它们同时也掩盖了一个令人不安的真相。因为当私营市场说一个地方无法投保时，这对居住在该地区的所有人来说都是一个警告信号：这个地方很危险。但州政府的计划却传递出了不同的信息。
They tell you this place is okay, or at least okay enough. And that's sort of the paradox. So we have these systems that have blinded people to risk and encouraged us all to live in very vulnerable places. And so many people have done that, that now we do have a very genuine need to protect some of those people. So on the one hand, as places all around the country face more and more severe climate threats, it's probably not a great idea to keep encouraging people to live in risky areas. But on the other hand, there already are a lot of people in those places. And if the state or the federal government refuse to step in when the private companies
它们告诉你这个地方没问题，或者至少足够安全。这就是某种悖论。所以我们拥有这些系统，它们蒙蔽了人们对风险的认知，并鼓励我们所有人住在非常脆弱的地方。太多人这样做了，以至于现在我们确实非常需要保护其中一部分人。因此一方面，随着全国各地面临越来越严重的气候威胁，继续鼓励人们住在危险地区可能不是个好主意；但另一方面，那些地方已经有了很多人。如果当私营公司逃离时，州或联邦政府拒绝介入，
flee, lots of people might be left without any insurance options at all. I own a home in California. I'm petrified of losing my insurance of the prospect of that. So I don't want to see my insurance go away. And if it were to go away, I don't want to see my state offered backstop go away because without it, I don't know what I would do. State-run home insurance programs and low-cost flood insurance have helped protect what is for most people, their most valuable asset.
许多人可能会完全失去任何保险选择。我在加州有一栋房子。我对失去保险的前景感到惊恐万状。所以我不想看到我的保险消失。如果它真的消失了，我也不希望看到州提供的后盾消失，因为没有它，我不知道我该怎么办。州营房屋保险计划和低成本洪水保险帮助保护了对大多数人而言最有价值的资产。
But they've also compounded a similar problem. They've made it harder for people to really consider the perils of living in a place like Cape Coral. But the risks were always there and they recently became plain for everyone to see. I'm looking for orange car. I see it. It's late August 2023, and I just pulled into a driveway where I'm greeted by Marion Morris. Hello. Hi, Jason.
但它们也加剧了一个类似的问题。它们使人们更难真正认真考虑住在像科勒尔角这样地方的危险。但风险一直都在，它们最近变得显而易见，所有人都能看得清清楚楚。我在找一辆橙色的车。我看见了。那是2023年8月下旬，我刚把车开进一条车道，玛丽安·莫里斯（Marion Morris）在那里迎接我。你好。嗨，杰森。
Yes, yes, yes, yes. You hear my baby? I hear the dogs. Marion lives in Cape Coral with her husband Lloyd and a handful of pets. On the day I visit, the heat index is right around 110, and a classic five o'clock storm is brewing outside. So to get out of this soupy mess,
对，对，对，对。你听到我的宝贝了吗？我听到狗叫了。玛丽安和她的丈夫劳埃德以及几只宠物住在科勒尔角。我访问那天，热指数高达110华氏度左右，一场典型的下午五点暴雨正在外面酝酿。为了躲避这种黏糊糊的闷热天气，
we move all the pleasantries into Marion's kitchen. There, she offers me some water, and I see a cat poke its head out from down the hall. On a table, Marion points to a very sweet family photo. That was me, believe it or not. That's you right there? Yeah, that's me and that's me. That's my husband. Look what age does to you. Guess what, you're not going to be so cute when you get older. Marion is in her 70s and recently retired. She moved to Cape Coral after her aunt passed away and left her this house.
我们把所有的寒暄转移到了玛丽安的厨房里。在那里，她端给我一些水，我看到一只猫从走廊深处探出头来。在桌子上，玛丽安指着一张非常温馨的家庭照片。信不信由你，那是我。那是你吗？对，那就是我。那是我的丈夫。看看岁月对你做了什么。你猜怎么着，当你老了之后，你可就没那么可爱了。玛丽安70多岁了，最近刚退休。她的阿姨去世后把这栋房子留给了她，她便搬到了科勒尔角。
It's a classic mid-century Florida ranch. Single story with a carport on the side and a lanai in the back. It's actually one of Golf American's original homes. But not just any of the original homes. A home in Florida! That's our home. Oh. Yeah. She lives in the place that was given away on the Price is Right all those years ago.
这是一栋典型的世纪中期佛罗里达牧场风格住宅。单层建筑，侧面带有一个车棚，后面有一个日光浴室。它实际上是“海湾美洲”最初建造的房屋之一。但可不仅仅是普通的最初房屋之一。佛罗里达的一栋房子！那是我们的家。哦。对。她就住在多年前在《价格猜猜看》上被当作奖品送出去的那个房子里。
Oh my God. There it is. Look. I played Mary in the clip you heard earlier on my phone while we huddled around her kitchen table. Did you know? So you didn't know any of that history of the Price is Right? No, and I don't think my aunt did either.
哦，天哪。就是那儿。你看。我们在她厨房桌子周围挤成一团时，我在手机上播放了你刚才听到的片段中的玛丽安。你知道吗？所以你对《价格猜猜看》的这段历史一无所知？不知道，我想我阿姨也不知道。
This was 61 or 62. I can't believe it, Price is Right? Marion was born in Ohio, and she first started coming down to Cape Coral in the 70s. That's when her aunt bought the place. I used to drive down here three, four times a year for vacation. To come down and see my aunt and uncle. And how were those vacations? How were they?
这是61或62年。我简直不敢相信，《价格猜猜看》？玛丽安出生在俄亥俄州，她最早在70年代开始来到科勒尔角。那是她阿姨买下这栋房子的时候。我过去常常一年开车下来三四次度假。下来看望我的阿姨和叔叔。那那些假期过得怎么样？怎么样？
Hot as heck. As the years went on, Marion couldn't help but notice all the changes that were happening in the city. More canals, more roads, and lots more people. Every time I came down, I said, oh my God, one of these days God's going to get mad and just bring a big wave and just wash it all away because they kept building and building and building and building. They took beautiful land and just destroyed it.
热得要命。随着时间的推移，玛丽安不由得注意到这座城市发生的所有变化。更多的运河、更多的道路，还有更多的人。每次我下来，我都说，“哦，天哪，总有一天上帝会生气的，然后掀起巨浪把这一切都冲走，”因为他们一直在建、一直建、一直建、一直建。他们把美丽的土地彻底毁了。
And that biblical wave that Marian was worried about, it finally came. In September 2022, Hurricane Ian made landfall not too far from Cape Coral. I mean, when it hits the fan, it hits the fan. So this is the first time the water ever came into the house. There's a saying that getting hit by a hurricane is a little like getting run over by a turtle. The days in the lead up to the storm are long. Everyone knows the latest forecast because everywhere you go, there's at least one TV tuned to the local news. You watch as the cone of uncertainty narrows.
而玛丽安一直担心的那场《圣经》般的巨浪，终于来了。2022年9月，飓风伊恩（Hurricane Ian）在离科勒尔角不远的地方登陆。我的意思是，当麻烦来临的时候，麻烦就全来了。所以这是水第一次涌进房子里。俗话说，遭遇飓风就像被乌龟碾过去一样漫长。风暴来临前的日子很长。每个人都知道最新的预报，因为无论你走到哪里，至少有一台电视调到了当地新闻。你看着不确定性圆锥不断缩小。
You go to Publix. You fill up your car. The storm spins in the opposite direction the clock ticks. You prepare on the off chance that it could be you, but no one ever feels ready when it is. Outside, it came all the way up to the bottom of the windows. To the bottom of the windows. Yeah. And it looked like a little mini tsunami running down the street. So the next thing you know this was also…
你去Publix超市。你给汽车加满油。风暴以与时钟滴答声相反的方向旋转。你做好了最坏的打算，万一灾难降临到你头上呢，但当它真的发生时，没有人会觉得自己已经准备好了。外面，水一直漫到了窗户底部。漫到了窗户底部。对。它看起来就像一股小型海啸顺着街道奔涌而下。所以接下来你知道的，这也……
You were here the entire time. Well, when you have three cats and two dogs, it's not likely you can run anywhere. Hurricane Ian was the strongest storm the area had ever seen, and one of the worst in the history of the country. It brought not only wind gusts of 140 miles per hour, but a massive storm surge. The Kalushahatchee River overflowed its banks, and so did lots of canals in the city. It was a worst-case scenario. A massive, slow-moving, rain-heavy storm.
你们一直都在这里。嗯，当你养了三只猫和两只狗时，你不太可能逃到任何地方。飓风伊恩是该地区有史以来经历的最强风暴，也是该国历史上最糟糕的风暴之一。它不仅带来了每小时140英里的阵风，还带来了巨大的风暴潮。卡卢萨哈奇河水泛滥，市内的许多运河也是如此。这是最糟糕的情况。一场大规模、移动缓慢、雨量充沛的风暴。
In parts of Cape Coral, high water marks were close to nine feet. When we started flooding, I picked up one dog, he picked up the other, and we put him on our tall dressers we had. And I'm sitting there on the one dresser of the chest and looking outside, and suddenly the shed that we had there, I watched the air just blow it apart from the inside out. It just went poof. It was horrible. The floodwater stayed in Marion's home overnight and receded by morning. When it was all said and done, she had two inches of mud to dig out of the house.
在科勒尔角的部分地区，高水位标志接近九英尺。当我们开始被淹时，我抱起一只狗，他抱起另一只，然后把它们放在我们家里那个高大的梳妆台上。我坐在其中一个五斗柜上向外看，突然我们放在那里的那个棚子，我看着气流直接把它从里到外吹得粉碎。它就这样“砰”的一声没了。太可怕了。洪水在玛丽安家里留了一夜，到早晨才退去。当这一切结束时，她得从家里清理出两英寸厚的烂泥。
She sifted through what could and couldn't be saved, furniture she inherited from her aunt, old remembrances. Anything waterlogged sat at the end of her driveway. We had trash piled up, seven, eight feet tall down around here. All you could see is mounds and mounds of stuff. Together, Marion and Lloyd restored kitchen cabinets, broke down old walls, and put in new floors, work they largely did with their own hands
她仔细挑拣着哪些东西可以保留、哪些不能，有她从姑妈那里继承的家具，还有过去的纪念品。所有被水浸泡过的东西都堆在她家车道尽头。我们这里的垃圾堆得有七、八英尺高。你一眼望去，全是一堆又一堆的杂物。玛丽莲和劳埃德一起修复了厨房橱柜，拆除了旧墙壁，铺上了新地板，这些活基本上都是他们亲手干的
and with their own money. We didn't have flood insurance. A lot of stuff came out of our pocket. It hit my, a lot of our savings. It really did. It did big time. I won't go into numbers and stuff, but it knocked us on our butt. Marion didn't have flood insurance in part because of some really big changes that the
而且是用他们自己的钱。“我们没有买洪水保险。很多开销都是我们自己掏的。这狠狠地冲击了我的储蓄，哦不，是我们的大部分储蓄。确实如此，影响太大了。我就不具体说数字了，但这真的是把我们打趴下了。”玛丽莲没有买洪水保险，部分原因是联邦政府对
federal government made to the National Flood Insurance Program. Just a few months before Hurricane Ian, FEMA finally decided to correct the premiums. So now a lot of residents are discovering what it looks like when the price matches the risk. Here's Carolyn Kuski again. FIMO is under pricing risk. And when you start accounting for it, premiums have to go up. And if you're going to have risk-based rates at a property level, they are going to be expensive in high risk areas, like along the Gulf Coast.
国家洪水保险计划（National Flood Insurance Program）做出了一些重大调整。就在伊恩飓风登陆前几个月，联邦紧急事务管理局（FEMA）终于决定纠正保费问题。所以现在许多居民正在发现，当价格与风险相符时会是什么样。我们再次听听卡罗琳·库斯基（Carolyn Kuski）的说法：“FEMA一直在低估风险。当你开始将其纳入考量时，保费就必然会上涨。如果你要在房屋层面上实行基于风险的费率，那么在高风险地区（如墨西哥湾沿岸），保费就会很昂贵。”
And the Gulf Coast is the area where we're seeing the biggest price increases. The NFIP's new pricing model is called Risk Rating 2.0. I know, it sounds a little dystopian. Risk Rating 2.0 more accurately prices the risk of each individual home, almost like a private insurer would. And Carolyn says that one of the counties experiencing the biggest rate hikes in Florida is Lee County,
而墨西哥湾沿岸正是我们看到价格涨幅最大的地区。NFIP的新定价模型被称为“风险评级2.0”（Risk Rating 2.0）。我知道，这听起来有点反乌托邦。风险评级2.0能更准确地为每栋独立房屋的风险定价，几乎就像私人保险公司那样。卡罗琳表示，佛罗里达州保费涨幅最大的县之一就是李县（Lee County），
where Cape Coral is located. The median premium under risk rating 2.0 is going to go up more than 250 percent. FEMA created a glide path for longtime policyholders that gradually increases rates over time. But for residents who just saw their city flood and now want a new flood policy, they're going to have to pay the full, more expensive rate. And some of the people that I spoke with say that 250% actually underestimates the changes they've been seeing. I called last year to see how much it would cost us to get flood insurance.
也就是开普科勒尔（Cape Coral）所在的县。在风险评级2.0下，中位保费将上涨250%以上。FEMA为长期投保人设立了一个缓冲期，在一段时间内逐渐提高保费。但对于那些刚经历过城市被淹、现在想要购买新的洪水保险的居民来说，他们将不得不支付全额的、更昂贵保费。我交谈过的一些人表示，250%实际上低估了他们所经历的变化。“我去年打电话询问购买洪水保险要花多少钱。”
They wanted $7,000. Marion Morris was among the first citizens whose flood insurance rates skyrocketed. When she called to ask about a policy, it was the month before Ian. Some longtime residents used to pay $500 or $600 for flood insurance every year. But Marion's $7,000 quote would have meant an extra $500 or $600 coming out of her pocket every month. For two seniors on a fixed income, they just couldn't swing it. So they didn't have flood insurance for one of the worst floods ever. They had to rebuild their home with their own money, and they still don't have insurance
“他们要价7000美元。”玛丽莲·莫里斯（Marion Morris）是最早遭遇洪水保险费飙升的市民之一。当她打电话咨询保单时，正好是伊恩飓风登陆前一个月。一些老居民过去每年只需支付500或600美元的洪水保险费。但玛丽莲收到的7000美元报价意味着，她每个月都要额外掏出500或600美元。对于靠固定收入生活的两位老人来说，这根本无法承担。因此，在遭遇史上最严重的洪水之一时，他们却没有买洪水保险。他们不得不自掏腰包重建家园，而且他们依然没有保险
to protect them from the next flood. When I spoke to Marion, she sounded defeated by the whole thing. The recovery, the financial gymnastics, the anxiety of summer, it's all just been too much. I'm just going to have to put it in God's hands. If it floods, it's not going to do me any good. You know, there's nothing I can do. You know, grin and bear it.
来保护他们免受下一场洪水的侵袭。当我与玛丽莲交谈时，她听起来被这一切彻底击垮了。重建的过程、财务上的腾挪、夏日的焦虑，这一切实在太沉重了。“我只能把这一切交托给上帝。如果发洪水了，对我也没有任何好处。你知道的，我无能为力。你知道的，只能逆来顺受。”
That's all. That's what we do. Everyone's having insurance issues. And insurance has become a nightmare in Florida all the way around. Again, Gloria Razo Tate, the daughter of Joseph Razo, who worked for the Rosens at Golf American. In addition to being one of the first residents of Cape Coral, Gloria has made a name for herself in the city. She's the owner of Razo Realty and has continued the tradition of her father, selling the Florida dream.
“那就这样吧。我们只能这样。每个人都有保险问题。在佛罗里达州，保险无论从哪个方面来说都成了一场噩梦。”再次说话的是格洛丽亚·拉索·泰特（Gloria Razo Tate），约瑟夫·拉索（Joseph Razo）的女儿，约瑟夫曾为罗森兄弟的“美国高尔夫”公司工作。作为开普科勒尔最早的居民之一，格洛丽亚不仅在当地小有名气，还是拉索地产（Razo Realty）的老板，她继承了父亲的传统，继续兜售着“佛罗里达梦”。
Back when Hurricane Ian hit, Gloria was also on the city council, representing the oldest part of the city and the one most affected by the hurricane. I mean, it's a year later and people are still not satisfied with their claims or still working through it. Gloria tells me that insurance, almost more than anything, has people reconsidering moving to Cape Coral. As a realtor selling property, I just shudder when I have to tell someone that they need flood insurance and where it's going to go.
在伊恩飓风袭来时，格洛丽亚还是市议员，代表着该市历史最悠久、受飓风影响最严重的地区。“我的意思是，一年过去了，人们对他们的理赔结果仍然很不满意，或者还在处理中。”格洛丽亚告诉我，保险问题甚至比其他任何事情都更能让人重新考虑是否要搬到开普科勒尔。作为一名出售房产的房地产经纪人，每当我不得不告诉某人他们需要买洪水保险以及保费将是多少时，我都会不寒而栗。
Have you seen that influence people in making decisions? Absolutely. Absolutely. Gloria worries that because risk rating 2.0 is so aggressive, eventually FEMA will place the entire city in a flood zone, which could dramatically increase the number of people with mortgages who'd have to purchase very expensive flood insurance. And Florida's state-run home insurance program, they're planning to increase rates too.
“你看到这种影响左右人们的决定了吗？”“绝对有，绝对有。”格洛丽亚担心，由于风险评级2.0过于激进，FEMA最终会将整个城市划入洪泛区，这可能会急剧增加背负房贷、不得不购买高昂洪水保险的人数。而佛罗里达州运营的房屋保险计划也计划提高保费。
Not exactly because of climate reasons, I don't know if you've heard, but the governor isn't really about that, but because he wants more people buying private insurance and getting off of the state's back. All of the experts that I spoke with for this story say that one of the first steps in untangling
这倒不完全是因为气候原因——我不知道你有没有听说过，州长其实并不太在乎这个——而是因为他希望更多的人购买私人保险，从而摆脱国家的负担。我在做这篇报道时采访的所有专家都表示，要解开
this insurance problem is to eventually price insurance accurately so that it reflects the amount of risk a homeowner is really facing. And that is starting to happen. It's just the way it's happening, it makes it almost impossible for people like Marion and Gloria, residents with roots in Cape Coral, who built a life here precisely because of its affordability. And that's one of the main criticisms of Risk Rating 2.0, that this new policy is going to hurt places like Cape Coral disproportionately, especially the working class people who live
这个保险问题，第一步就是要最终准确地为保险定价，使其能够反映房主真正面临的风险水平。而这正在发生。只是这种发生的方式，让像玛丽莲和格洛丽亚这样的人——那些在开普科勒尔扎根、正是因为这里生活成本低廉才在此建立生活的人——几乎变得无法承受。这也是对风险评级2.0的主要批评之一，即这项新政策将不成比例地伤害开普科勒尔这样的地方，尤其是那些住在在那里的工人阶级。
there. And it has. But that's also because that's kind of the point. It's supposed to hurt. In that respect, the 2.0 and the FEMA maps and all of that, they are here to protect us. It's just they weren't here at the beginning. And the retrofit can bankrupt most people.
而且确实如此。但这也是因为这正是它的意义所在。它本该带来痛苦。从这个意义上说，2.0版本、FEMA的地图以及所有这些，它们存在是为了保护我们。只是它们一开始并不存在。而事后改造会让大多数人破产。
The retrofit is painful. The retrofit is painful, yeah. Gloria tells me that since the hurricane, people have had to make some really hard choices about where they live. Including her. Because Ian destroyed her home too. I had almost four feet of water in my home. A sewer line break.
改造是痛苦的。改造是痛苦的，是的。格洛丽亚告诉我，自飓风发生以来，人们不得不对自己的居住地做出一些非常艰难的选择。包括她自己。因为伊恩也摧毁了她的家。“我家里有将近四英尺深的水。下水道管线破裂。”
I had a 62-year-old tree that fell in the middle of my house and that was that. I was in shock. So it took me a few days to actually wrap myself around it, what had happened. And meanwhile, I was on the city council responsible for an entire city, also a realtor trying to find people housing and it was a nightmare come true. In the aftermath of Ian, Gloria wanted nothing more than to rebuild her home. But it was right on the coast and subject to something called the 50% rule. The 50% rule is yet another FEMA regulation that made life after the storm harder for residents.
“我有一棵62岁的老树倒在了房子正中间，事情就是这样。我当时处于震惊之中。所以我花了几天时间才真正接受现实，接受所发生的一切。”与此同时，她还是个身负整个城市责任的市议员，也是一个试图为人们寻找住房的房地产经纪人，这真是一场噩梦成真。伊恩飓风过后，格洛丽亚最渴望的就是重建家园。但她的房子正好在海岸边，受制于所谓的“50%规则”。“50%规则”是FEMA的又一项规定，它让居民在风暴后的生活变得更加艰难。
The idea is that any home in a high-risk flood zone that's damaged by more than half of its value needs to get rebuilt up to the latest building codes. Which for older homes in Cape Coral like Gloria's, more often than not means elevating the whole house a few feet. The rule is in place to force communities in risky areas to build back better. The rule is in place to force communities in risky areas to build back better, so that the next time another hurricane comes around, the home has a better chance at surviving the storm. Here's Wyatt Daltrey again, Cape Coral's floodplain manager. No one likes the rule. We understand it.
这个想法是：高风险洪泛区内的任何房屋，如果受损程度超过其价值的一半，就需要按照最新的建筑规范进行重建。对于像格洛丽亚这样开普科勒尔的老房子来说，这往往意味着将整栋房子抬高几英尺。这条规定的出台是为了迫使处于危险地区的社区把房子建得更好。这条规定的出台是为了迫使处于危险地区的社区把房子建得更好，这样当下一次飓风来临时，房屋在风暴中存活下来的几率就会更大。我们再次听听怀亚特·达尔特雷（Wyatt Daltrey）的说法，他是开普科勒尔的洪泛区经理。“没有人喜欢这条规则。我们能理解它。”
It's a good rule, just a rule that no one likes. After the storm, Wyatt's job only got harder. He spent months sending out letters to people to tell them their homes were too badly damaged and that if they wanted to rebuild them, they'd need to elevate the entire house. An extremely expensive proposition. He spent hours on the phone getting yelled at. It's hard telling people, you know, well, you've had this tragedy occur to your home.
“这是一条好规则，只是没人喜欢它。”风暴过后，怀亚特的工作变得更加艰难。他花了几个月的时间给人们发信，告诉他们房屋受损严重，如果想重建，就需要把整栋房子抬高。这是一个极其昂贵的提议。他花了好几个小时接听电话，挨骂。“告诉别人这些很难，你知道的，‘嗯，你的家遭遇了这场悲剧。’”
Now we're like compounding that by saying, well, you're going to have to make a very important decision. What I find so interesting about the 50% rule is that it gets to the heart of attention in how we respond to climate change. Of course, we want public policy to encourage citizens to build back with the future in mind. We want a government that for once is being proactive instead of reactive to what's happening in our new climate. But we also want a government that takes care of its people.
“现在我们又雪上加霜地对他们说，‘嗯，你将不得不做出一个非常重大的决定。’”关于“50%规则”，我觉得最有趣的是，它触及了我们在应对气候变化时面临的核心矛盾。当然，我们希望公共政策能够鼓励市民在重建时将未来考虑在内。我们希望政府能够一反常态，采取积极主动而非被动应对的方式来面对新气候下发生的事情。但我们也希望政府能够照顾好它的人民。
And the 50 percent rule shows how after a storm, it's hard to do both of those things at the same time. Bill Spikowski, the local city planner, told me that long term thinking around Southwest Florida is hard and damn near impossible after a storm. Understandably, people just want to get back into their homes. So when you get a letter from Wyatt saying you need to do X and Y and Z. Nobody can hear that as a good thing. They can only hear that as the government stomping on us.
而“50%规则”表明，在风暴过后，要同时做到这两件事是多么困难。当地城市规划师比尔·斯皮科夫斯基（Bill Spikowski）告诉我，在风暴过后，围绕佛罗里达州西南部的长期思考是困难的，几乎是不可能的。可以理解的是，人们只想搬回自己的家。所以，当你收到怀亚特的一封信，说你需要做甲、乙、丙的事情时。没有人会觉得这是件好事。他们只会觉得这是政府在把我们踩在脚下。
How did you hear that as someone who lives in this area? I feel it both ways. So I'm often on the person trying to answer the question, what do we do about climate change? But I've also personally been through two really, really bad hurricanes, and I have friends and neighbors, lots of them, who've been through this. And I'm just completely torn, because I think, you know, like, both are true, yet how can both be true?
作为这个地区的一名居民，你是怎么看待这一点的？我对此有双重感受。我经常扮演那个试图回答“我们该如何应对气候变化”这一问题的人；但我自己也经历过两次非常非常糟糕的飓风，我有很多朋友和邻居都经历过这一切。我感到无比纠结，因为我想，你知道的，这两点都是真的，然而怎么可能两点都对呢？
How can it both be the right thing and completely the wrong thing? Do you make this easier on the citizens of your community, or do you take the big picture view that everybody should rebuild the pyre because the waters are coming up? Do you make this easier on the citizens of your community, or do you take the big picture view that everybody should rebuild the pyre because the waters are coming up? For people like Gloria, the 50% rule is what stood between her and rebuilding her home. The last place she ever lived with her husband. One of the first quarter acre lots the Rosen brothers ever built. To her, it was a home with a lot of personal history
怎么可能既是正确的事情，又完全是错误的事情？你是应该让社区居民的生活更轻松一点，还是应该从宏观大局出发，认为所有人都应该重新建高房子，因为水位正在上涨？你应该是应该让社区居民的生活更轻松一点，还是应该从宏观大局出发，认为所有人都应该重新建高房子，因为水位正在上涨？对于像格洛丽亚这样的人来说，“50%规则”就是横亘在她与重建家园之间的大山。那是她和丈夫一起生活过的最后一个地方。罗森兄弟建造的第一批四分之一英亩地块之一。对她来说，这是一处充满个人历史的家
and history to the city, even if it was only slightly above sea level. Still, Gloria knew elevating the house was just one of a seemingly endless number of things the home needed to be lived in again. New walls, new floors, new everything. I took it down to the studs and then I just sold it for land value. Gloria told me that she wanted to rebuild the right way,
也承载着这座城市的历史，尽管它只比海平面高出一点点。尽管如此，格洛丽亚知道，把房子抬高只是为了让房子能够重新住人而看似无穷无尽的事情中的一件。新墙壁、新地板，一切都要换新的。“我把它拆到只剩龙骨，然后直接按土地价值把它卖了。”格洛丽亚告诉我，她本想以正确的方式重建，
getting the home up to the proper building standards. But after the storm, she looked around the city and saw lots of people who had a massive amount of damage just putting their homes back together again. 50% rule be damned. Did you elevate? No. Did you do this? No. Where are your permits? I didn't get them. And lots of homes in these areas are being fixed and rebuilt and they're not going to be insurable. A few months ago, FEMA actually put out a statement saying that a bunch of residents in Cape Coral violated some floodplain regulations, including the 50 percent rule.
让房屋达到适当的建筑标准。但在风暴过后，她环顾这座城市，看到许多遭受了巨额损失的人只是把房子重新拼凑起来，“50%规则”见鬼去吧。“你抬高房子了吗？没有。”“你做了这个吗？没有。”“你的许可证呢？我没办。”这些地区的许多房屋正在被修缮和重建，而且它们将无法获得保险。几个月前，FEMA确实发表了一份声明，称开普科勒尔的一群居民违反了一些洪泛区规定，包括“50%规则”。
The city did push back, but unless it somehow addresses the problems FEMA found, flood insurance could get even more expensive for all of the residents of Cape Coral. flood insurance could get even more expensive for all of the residents of Cape Coral. Bill says that as insurance prices keep creeping up, an interesting phenomenon is taking shape in some of the riskiest parts of southwest Florida. It's not just the poor and the working class who are forgoing coverage, but increasingly rich folks are opting out too. Which if you're wealthy, you can self-insure, which means really having no insurance. After Hurricane Ian, lots of big corporate money moved into the places that were the
该市确实进行了回击，但除非它能以某种方式解决FEMA发现的问题，否则开普科勒尔所有居民的洪水保险可能会变得更加昂贵。洪水保险可能会变得更加昂贵。比尔说，随着保险价格不断攀升，一种有趣的现象正在佛罗里达州西南部一些风险最高的地区成形。不仅是穷人和工人阶级在放弃购买保险，越来越多的富人也选择不买。如果你很有钱，你可以自保，这意味着实际上没有任何保险。伊恩飓风过后，大量企业资本涌入受灾最严重的地方，并以现金购买房屋，这意味着他们不必购买洪水保险，甚至根本不需要任何保险。他们可以只是赌一把，希望当下一场风暴袭来时，FEMA能在最后关头介入帮他们一把。所以你看到的情况是，有钱人搬进这些遭受灾害袭击的地区并迅速买下，因为他们是唯一买得起的人。而这种情况只会变得越来越糟糕。
most severely hit and bought homes in cash, which means they don't have to have flood insurance or really any insurance at all. They can just take the gamble and hope that maybe FEMA comes in on the back end to help them out when the next storm rolls through. So what you have is people of means moving in and swooping in in these areas that have been hit by disasters because they're the only ones who can afford to do it. And that's just going to be getting worse and worse.
你看到这种情况在这里发生了吗？绝对的，这已经在发生了。更糟糕的是。你看到这种情况在这里发生了吗？绝对的，这已经在发生了。今年2月，在我最后一次驱车穿过这座城市时，我去了开普科勒尔的最南端，大约70年前罗森兄弟首次在这里动工的地方。我……当我八月份开车穿过这里时，这里还没这么挤。现在这里有太多人了。那是一个绝对晴朗的日子。这真是一个提醒，让人明白为什么在这个地方，人们总是那么容易忘记上一场风暴。
You see that happening here? Absolutely, it's already happening here. worse. You see that happening here? Absolutely. It's already happening here. This past February, on my last drive through the city, I took a trip down to Cape Coral's most southern point, where the Rosens first broke ground nearly 70 years ago. I just when I drove through here in August, it was not this packed. There's just a lot of people here now. It was an absolutely gorgeous day. A real reminder of why around here, it's so easy to forget the last storm.
在水边的一条路上，施工队几乎在每一栋房子上都在加紧施工，距离伊恩飓风过去近两年后，这里仍在重建。很多地方仍在施工，也有一些新的建设正在进行。我之所以开车来这里，是因为我想看看格洛丽亚·拉索·泰特的老房子——就是那栋在四英尺深的河水摧毁它之后，她不得不将其拆光并出售的房子，是那个她住了27年、直到一堵水墙将其彻底夺走的地方。这就是格洛丽亚的老房子。中间过去有一棵树，现在没有了，但看起来已经被修饰、翻新过了。
On one road down by the water, construction crews were hard at work on nearly every home, still rebuilding from Hurricane Ian almost two years later. A lot of places still under construction, some new construction going on. I took this drive because I wanted to see Gloria Razotate's old home, the one she had to gut and sell after four feet of river destroyed it, the place where she lived for 27 years before a wall of water took it all away. So this is Gloria's old home. Used to be a tree in the middle no longer, but it looks like it's been touched up, redone.
这房子看起来很新，而且值得注意的是，它没有被抬高。依然像煎饼一样平平地躺在同一块地面上——几英尺外就是“美国高尔夫”从河底疏浚出的水域。后来，在查阅一些公共记录时，我发现格洛丽亚的房子实际上是被一家有限责任公司（LLC）买下的，那是那些趁火打劫的投资者之一，他们利用这场风暴作为捞便宜货的借口。我绕着格洛丽亚的老街区开了一圈，光是她的这条街上就有七栋房子
The home looked new, and notably, it had not been elevated. Still flat as a pancake on the same ground, Golf American dredged out of the depths of the river a few feet away. Later, while digging through some public records, I saw that Gloria's home was actually purchased by an LLC, one of those investors who swooped in, using the storm as an excuse for a good deal. I drove in a loop around Gloria's old block, counted seven homes
挂牌出售，我确信还会有更多。我驶出街区，重新回到主干道上。我回想着我所长大的那个佛罗里达，以及我正驱车穿过的这个佛罗里达，我不禁感到，我们正在接近一个时代的尾声——那是一个我们通过操纵足够的土地和资金，让这样一个地方变得合理的时代。因为在这个街区的这个角落，在这个“佛罗里达梦”开始的地方，它看起来并不像人间天堂。它看起来像个遗迹。就好像我已经用过去时在看待它一样。
listed for sale on her street alone, with I'm sure a lot more to come. I exit the loop and I'm back out on the main road. I think about the Florida that I grew up in and the one that I'm driving through, and I can't help but feel that we're approaching the end of an era, a time when we manipulated enough land and finances to make a place like this make sense. Because on this one block, in this one corner of the city where the Florida Dream started, it didn't look like paradise. It looked like a relic. As if I was already seeing it in the past tense.
下期《不适宜生存》预告……随着气候变化以及人们继续涌入易受洪水侵袭的地区，全国各地的洪水风险都在增加。在我们有生之年以及我们孩子的有生之年，这条风险线将会不断增长。我们已经陷入了将持续下去的变暖和海平面上升中。对于如何应对这一局面，我们目前还没有好的政策答案。但越来越多的决策者开始认同这样一种观点：我们可能需要开始彻底放弃一些风险最高的地区，让住在那里的人们远离危险。
Next time on Not Built For This… Flood risk is increasing all across the country as the climate changes and people continue to move into flood-prone areas. That line of risk is going to be growing for our lifetimes and our children's lifetimes. We have locked into warming and sea level rise that's going to continue. We don't have good policy answers yet for how to handle that. But more and more, policymakers are coming around to the idea that we might need to start abandoning some of the most risky places altogether, and get the people living there out of harm's way.
这说起来容易做起来难。我们不知道该如何在极端高风险地区进行公平的“去建设”（unbuild），我认为这将是我们数十年来的难题。在下一集中，我们将前往路易斯安那州西南部，看看拆除一个易受洪水侵袭的社区会是什么样子，以及那个被称为“有计划撤退”（managed retreat）的苦乐参半、痛苦的过程。
Which is a lot easier said than done. We don't know how to equitably unbuild in high-risk areas, and I think this is going to be our problem for decades. In our next episode, we head to southwest Louisiana to see what it looks like to unbuild a flood-prone neighborhood and the bittersweet, painful process known as managed retreat.
我说，好吧，就像直接开个推土机过去一样，现在就把它直接推倒。我不在乎。我对这栋房子已经没有任何情感上的依恋了。本期《不适宜生存》由杰森·德莱昂（Jason DeLeon）和我——埃梅特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）共同报道并制作，制作人还有苏菲·科德纳（Sophie Coddner），管理编辑是德兰妮·霍尔（Delaney Hall）。克里斯托弗·约翰逊（Christopher Johnson）、乔·罗森伯格（Joe Rosenberg）、凯利·普赖姆（Kelly Prime），当然还有我们的船长罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）提供了宝贵的编辑指导。混音和声音设计由马丁·甘萨雷斯（Martín González）完成。主题曲
I said, well, it's like a bulldozer to go straight through right now, pull it right out. I don't care. There's no emotional attachment to the house anymore. This episode of Not Built For This was reported and produced by Jason DeLeon and me, Emmett Fitzgerald, along with producers Sophie Coddner and managing editor Delaney Hall. Further invaluable editing from Christopher Johnson, Joe Rosenberg, Kelly Prime, and of course our captain Roman Mars. Mix and sound design by Martín González. Theme
和原创音乐由来自Actual Magic的乔治·兰格福德（George Langford）创作，附加音乐由斯旺·拉约尔（Swan Rayall）提供。事实核查由格雷厄姆·海沙（Graham Haysha）负责。系列美术由亚伦·内斯特（Aaron Nestor）设计。特别感谢佛罗里达大学塞缪尔·普罗克托口述历史项目的黛博拉·亨德里克斯（Deborah Hendricks），以及采访并记录了
and original music by George Langford from Actual Magic, with additional music by Swan Rayall. Fact-checking by Graham Haysha. Series art by Aaron Nestor. A very special thanks to Deborah Hendricks at the University of Florida's Samuel Proctor Oral History Program, and to David Dodrill, who interviewed and recorded
大量“美国高尔夫”公司前员工的戴维·多德里尔（David Dodrill）。他的书《兜售梦想》（Selling the Dream）提供了关于开普科勒尔早期居民最全面的第一手口述记录。还要非常感谢所有接受我们采访的人，特别是杰森·皮姆（Jason Pym）、谢丽尔·安德森（Cheryl Anderson）、马克斯·福吉（Max Forgey）、约瑟夫和保罗·博纳西亚（Joseph and Paul Bonasia）、韦恩·达尔特雷（Wayne Daltrey）以及克雷格·皮特曼（Craig Pittman）。《不适宜生存》是99%隐形节目（99% Invisible）推出的六集系列节目。新节目将于每周二和周五在99PI的节目源中更新，你可以在任何收听播客的地方找到它。
a lot of the former employees at Gulf American. His book, Selling the Dream, offers the most comprehensive set of first-person accounts from early residents of Cape Coral. Another big thanks to everyone who spoke with us for this story and specifically Jason Pym, Cheryl Anderson, Max Forgey, Joseph and Paul Bonasia, Wayne Daltrey, and Craig Pittman. Not Built for This is a six part series from 99% Invisible. New episodes will be coming to you in the 99PI feed on Tuesdays and Fridays, wherever you get your podcasts.
凯西·图（Kathy Tu）是我们的执行制作人。柯克·霍尔斯特德（Kirk Holstead）是我们的数字总监。99PI团队的其他成员包括克里斯·佩鲁韦（Chris Perube）、维维安·莱（Vivian Lay）、拉沙·马顿（Lasha Madon）、加布里埃拉·格拉德尼（Gabriela Gladney）、雅各布·马尔多纳多-梅迪纳（Jacob Maldonado-Medina）和尼娜·波图克（Nina Potuck）。99%隐形的标志由斯特凡·劳伦斯（Stefan Lawrence）创作。我们是Stitcher和SiriusXM播客大家庭的一部分。你可以在所有常规社交媒体网站以及我们的全新Discord
Kathy Tu is our executive producer. Kirk Holstead is our digital director. The rest of the 99PI team includes Chris Perube, Vivian Lay, Lasha Madon, Gabriela Gladney, Jacob Maldonado-Medina, and Nina Potuck. The 99% Invisible logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. We are a part of the Stitcher and SiriusXM podcast family. You can find 99% Invisible on all the usual social media sites, as well as our new Discord
服务器上找到99%隐形。在99pi.org上可以找到相关链接，以及99PI和《不适宜生存》的每一集节目。本集节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。
server. There's a link to that, as well as every episode of 99PI and Not Built For This, at 99pi.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
服务器。您可以在 99pi.org 找到相关链接，以及 99PI 和 Not Built For This 的每一期节目。本期节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。